hello everyone and a special welcome to
all you extraterrestrials that have been
equalized hello
hello
hello this is versus i'm your host mark
allison today on the show mr smith goes
to washington sorry to rile up all you
jimmy stewart fans but that mr smith
will be staying home for this
scintillating cinematic showdown we're
pitting will smith up against denzel
washington and a thrilling thespian
thinker let's hit the throttle 50 000
men
died right here
on this field
fighting
the same fight
and we're still fighting amongst
ourselves
today in one corner you have the
ultimate entertainer so beloved he's
laid claim to his own summertime holiday
mr fourth of july himself will smith
music tv and i hear he makes movies now
too the guy's been in a-lister for
decades now thanks to his tussles with
aliens his bouts in the ring and his
bromance for the great martin lawrence
in the other corner it's the actor's
actor who also happens to be one of the
greatest to ever stand on a mark while a
director shouts action
right all right
denzel washington whose glory has been
on full display in roles ranging from
the civil war to the civil rights
movement to the civil unrest of the
futuristic masterpiece virtuosity oh and
did i mention that denzel was also great
in a boxing movie or that will smith
also played an iconic civil rights
figure this might be the greatest
matchup in the storied history of this
show the guy who saved earth and had a
lot of fun doing it is taking on the guy
who saved dakota fanning and we had a
lot of fun watching it here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three iconic rolls round
four i make this look good and then
we'll do a wild card round that could
involve the magnificent seven pounds or
made an american gangster you know you
think i wouldn't have these two fellows
movies confused right it seems like one
is always an oscar contention and the
other stars are the biggest blockbusters
known to humankind but denzel was
already a bankable star when will smith
was still shooting some b-ball outside
his high school but after moving in with
his auntie and uncle in bel air mr smith
became a fixture in the award circuit
just like sir washington will and denzel
are going to attest to the winner goes
the glory and the loser goes to the wild
wild west but these two legends are more
than just a couple of john q's and
they're separated by a lot less than six
degrees let's get it on round one box
offers both smith and washington have
forged mythologically great careers in
hollywood by being able to play just
about anything on the big screen luckily
for this round their films frequently
play to sold out movie theaters around
the world and since earth welcome to
denzel washington before will smith we
will start with today's elder statesman
though if you call him old you'll find
out he's much more than just a home
depot employee real quick the old man's
got to be the old man fish got to be the
fish after finding success on the small
screen with 1980s hit show saint
elsewhere denzel washington began to
find his footing in the world of cinema
exploding onto the scene with his
oscar-winning supporting turn in 1989's
glory and although that film only took
in 26 million dollars at the worldwide
box office that would prove to be just
the starting point after 1992's malcolm
x almost doubled glory's earnings denzel
would have a banner 1993 that included
smash hits philadelphia and the pelican
brief that's when bill would combine for
almost 400 million dollars as would the
double feature of his two equalizer
flicks decades later but as of today the
biggest earner on washington's resume is
the one that i find myself rewatching
the most american gangster from 2007.
the denzel russell crowe tussle would
pull in 267 million dollars worldwide
beat that will to which will smith would
probably respond whoo
and who wouldn't after looking at that
scrooge mcduck-worthy bank account
numbers hauled in by this platinum
superstar will smith came onto the big
screen smoking hot from the hit sitcom
the fresh prince of bel air and
immediately had an impact his supporting
role in the 1993 whoopi goldberg ted
danson rom-com made in america helped
solidify the movie as a 100 million
dollar barrier breaker a harbinger of
things to come in smith's filmography
two years later bad boys would earn 141
million dollars worldwide and the next
year a little alien movie came on fourth
of july weekend independence day
shattered records and nuked the
competition on its way to a take
exceeding 800 million dollars and it
wasn't the last time will would tussle
with baddies from another planet relax
independence day resurgence not talking
about you how many times do i have to
remind everybody on this show the
council of versus which is me does not
and will never recognize that
independence day resurgence was ever a
film that actually happened i was
talking about the men in black trilogy
which has grossed over 1.5 billion
dollars in earth credits 2020's bad boys
for life earned over 400 million dollars
2007's i am legend took in almost 600
million hancock would exceed that number
the next year suicide squad they have
745 million dollars and i haven't even
mentioned the top earner on will's beefy
resume can you even see it it's like
looking at the top of mount everest and
i've ever climbed that rock one day i
hope there's a genie and a lamp that can
get me down in a gif 2019's aladdin
earned 1.04
billion dollars and will smith might
have been the only person on this planet
or any other realm that could have
stepped into the shoes of the great
robin williams all told will smith films
have totaled
9.59 billion dollars worldwide which
more than doubles denzel's haul of 4.29
billion dollars it's still an impressive
take and that makes for a 91 million
dollar per flick average for washington
and here's a step that's going to make
that feat all the more impressive 30 of
denzel's 47 total theatrical releases
have been rated r you're knocking on the
door of 100 million dollar movie average
even with all the kitties barred from
your doors and making all those tiny
award-friendly pictures
i humbly bow before thee maybe just get
us a few more equalizers and we'll get
over 100 million dollars but you don't
want to climb the beanstalk and upset
the giant that is will smith and his
gaudy digits his perflic average is an
astonishing 309
million dollars per movie and that's
just the start he's been on multiple
runs where he's had four five six seven
films in a row across the 100 million
dollar mark and between 2004 and 2008
all of his films took in at least 300
million dollars he's amongst the most
popular performers ever for a reason
kids props to denzel for having 22
movies gross over 100 million dollars
internationally will has 23 but that's
about as close as this round is gonna
get will smith cashes in on his mr
fourth of july reputation and wins round
one i mean even wild wild west made 221
million dollars how it helped him in
this round but as for the next one who's
the man huh who's the man round two
tomato meter slash audience score yeah
it'll be a tough road to hoe for will
not just because of that western comedy
that borrowed a giant spider originally
intended to be in tim burton's superman
lives what happened but also because
denzel washington is here not in the
building but in this match and i think
round one might have made him angry so
while he simmers let's see what will has
in the oven in the phase where critical
and audience reception is paramount he's
actually got some freshness and that
pleasant scent isn't limited to just one
decade the 2021 acclaimed film king
richard is 91 on the tomato meter just
one percentage point shy of will's
all-time high mark
1997's men in black six degrees of
separation established the funny sitcom
hip-hop kid as a quality dramatic actor
and it's sitting pretty at 88 fresh the
guy can win over critics in any genre
the rom-com hitch the tech thriller
enemy of the state they're both fresh as
are all three bad boys films oh no in my
heart they're fresh on the tomato meter
bad boys for life is the first two sadly
rotten as is men in black too which is
curious because men in black three got
back to fresh and that movie almost made
me quit watching movies i can't stand it
that being said i'd still like will to
come back to the franchise so he and
tommy lee jones can team up with the 21
jump street kids and violent hilarity
would ensue i'm the only one on that
bandwagon still all right moving on to
the goat no not the guy who plays sports
down in tampa bay i'm referring to
denzel washington who's not only
considered one of the best of his
generation but of any generation like
ever we know he'll be great in anything
but with the movies he's great and be
able to equalize that i used that joke
too many times didn't i well look the
equalizer is fresh at 60 percent it's a
good start oh and denzel has six movies
that rate above 90 on the tomato meter
and a baker's dozen flicks that are in
the 80 range you talk about lasting
relevance his all-time standard is 93
percent which is shared by two movies
glory from 1989 and the tragedy of
macbeth from like a couple months ago
speaking of shakespeare much to do about
nothing is it 90 but if you prefer your
play-to-screen adaptations a little more
modern august wilson's fences from 2016
is at 92 percent malcolm x is 89 crimson
tide is 88 at 87 percent is unstoppable
and so is denzel does the guy have any
rotten movies well yeah he's got some
duds john q and the bone collector are
in the 20s but you can still see him on
cable all the time virtuosity is 32 and
38
is man on fire what
that's a crime against everything pure
and good in this world unjustly rotten
films aside denzel washington still has
a fresh per-film average on the tomato
meter at 66 percent where's the
hurricane 83 okay he should have won an
oscar for that just saying american
gangster said 81 and that movie should
have won every oscar that year i don't
care what the category special effects
makeup lifetime achievement the movie
should have hosted the ceremony it's a
good movie and i'm done will smith's
tomato meter per film average puts up a
good fight but is rotten and is still
respectable 52
and no doubt it was movies like wild
wild west at 17 percent that did him in
but he's got two films below that
stinker after earth this is all-time
limbo bar at 11
and collateral beauty is 14 but don't
worry independence day is safe at fresh
at 68
you want to know what the non-captain
stephen hillard sequel is yeah
independence day resurgence is 30
and it's still way too high if will
wants to win this round he's got to make
up a ton of ground in a hurry with the
audience score and he's making headway
his average per film over here is a
fresh 69
thanks to recent crowd pleasers like
aladdin at 94 percent bad boys the third
at 96 percent and king richard earning
its crown at 98
but denzel is beloved as well and fan
favorites like remember the titans at 93
percent and training day at 89 percent
have entered the chat will gets the best
of denzel here by just one percent as
washington approves upon his tomato
meteor average by a couple up to a 68
per film average for the audience score
both actors have not only remained
relevant over multiple decades they're
still on top of their respective games
actually have i not tossed in he got
game yet it's at 81 on the tomato meter
and oh right it stars ray allen who
broke my spurs loving heart with a gut
punch three-pointer in the nba finals
how'd the season afterwards go miami
heat yeah i remember we won revenge is
sweet and winning's fun so as denzel
washington now knows from taking this
round it's all tied up at one a piece
you are breaking my heart here kid round
three iconic roles so yeah it's safe to
say that critics and audiences love
these actors and fans around the world
wind up in droves to see their new
talking pictures and a big reason why is
because will smith and denzel washington
are able to either disappear into a role
or play a character that's so perfectly
in tune with our expectations take a
look at any one decade in the career of
smith or washington and you're likely to
find more iconic performances than most
a-list stars would have in a lifetime
muhammad ali malcolm x yes those are
vital historical figures but they were
also brought to new life by will smith
and denzel washington and both actors
were nominated for an academy award as a
thank you so let's start there the most
prestigious award show of the year gives
out a killer goodie bag and is a good
measuring stick for how impactful role
actually was will smith has been
nominated for two oscars so far and most
folks named mark think it should have
been three when he played dr bennett
omalu in concussion and to tell the
truth he might have his third by the
time you're watching this for his
portrayal of king richard venus and
serena williams's father his prior two
nods were in 2007 for the pursuit of
happiness and in 2002 for ali we can
actually stay in the boxing ring for
denzel's oscar highlights he was
nominated for his turn as reuben carter
in the hurricane and once again the
international council of marx thought he
should have taken home oscar gold for
that effort but denzel will just have to
be content with his two wins best
supporting actor for glory and best lead
actor for training day other nominations
include everything from cry freedom to
roman j israel esquire to flight ooh
flight is really really good go see
flight denzel's been nominated eight
times total so far and again he might be
competing against will smith at the 2022
ceremony be kind of fun to have a king
take on macbeth right no
but those are just their recent quality
performances if you really want the best
of all time i'd look at denzel
washington in malcolm x spike lee's
kinetic filmmaking meshed perfectly with
washington's pitch perfect portrayal of
the civil rights leader it shouldn't be
lost on audiences how important roles
like malcolm x private trip from glory
and coach herman boone from a member of
the titans r not just to denzel
washington's career but to the very
fabric of american cinema and while will
smith proved his serious chops as far
back as 1993 with six degrees of
separation and again as chris gardner in
the pursuit of happiness and robert nebo
and i am legend smith has become iconic
for a different reason he's just so
charming and likable and charismatic and
cool we can all relate to him even if
we'll never be anywhere as close to as
popular he took what it was to be an
everyman and upped the ante it doesn't
matter if he's thrust into a situation
like saving the world in independence
day or is it genie in aladdin we
obviously can't relate to what it's like
to be a shape-shifting myth or a fighter
pilot but we all want to think that if
we were we'd enjoy it as much as we love
watching will smith play out our
fantasies even when he's dealing with
hardcore baddies and action movies like
bad boys or irobot he does so with such
an enthusiasm and relentless positive
energy that we never get tired of seeing
it and it's those blockbuster parts like
agent k from men in black that make his
more down to earth no pun intended roles
in movies like seven pounds that much
more memorable it's too easy to make
this round about the fun of will smith
against the seriousness of denzel
washington well it's a game i'm just
joking around now while washington may
not be in a lot of comedies he can add
moxie to anything especially action
flicks like two guns deja vu and the
equalizer combo and ask any fan of
violent movies which ones are high up
there on their list they're going to say
man on fire at the top just about every
time captain stephen hillard agent k and
bad boys as mike have made will smith
into one of the biggest stars planet
movie has ever seen and will smith's
dramatic roles have cemented him as one
of the best working actors of the last
30 years but for me the acclaim and
awards denzel washington has earned over
his career match that of just about
anyone not named meryl streep but unlike
so many other awards show staples denzel
can also match wits with ryan reynolds
in safe house hoop with jesus
shuttlesworth and represent tom hanks in
the groundbreaking philadelphia another
oscar nomination he received with what
he wasn't even nominated for that
uh dear academy it's mark again i'll
give will smith a few more roses for his
levity and animated films like a shark
tale and spies in disguise but denzel
washington might have beat anyone in a
round about iconic roles whether it's
fiction like training days alonzo
non-fiction like frank lucas and
american gangster or fiction so
compelling it feels real like pilot whip
whitaker from flight washington has all
the bases covered will smith of the
movies might be on a part with muhammad
ali's legacy in the ring but this round
is a knockout for denzel he takes the w
and now he has a 2-1 lead over the fresh
prince
it's probably king by now right yeah
it's the fresh king you're sick so i see
something is wrong with you you have a
problem and you should have yourself
checked round four i make this look good
yeah i sure do but fitting as that wine
may be for your dashing host i didn't
come up with it
i make this look good that was agent k
and the og men in black a movie i did
see opening weekend with my pals and we
sure had a lot of memorable moments to
gush about afterwards if you haven't
picked up on it yet that's what this
round is all about the scenes sequences
and screen synergy that we remember for
a lifetime and if it's memorable moments
you want and a symbiotic buddy
relationship that's gonna help you get
there here come the men in black but not
before we get some bad boys what you
gonna do indeed besides cram popcorn
into your face at ferrari speeds
watching mike and martin lawrence's
marcus wreck shop all over miami to put
some nerdy wells behind bars michael bay
had the perfect pairing with smith and
lawrence both had huge sitcoms in the
early 90s and martin lawrence was
rightfully the headliner of that first
bad boys film but selling it was will
smith looking fresh but not like a
pampered prince the slo-mo shot of him
running like dion sanders and built like
bo jackson seems like the white
supremacist infiltration that opens up
bad boys too would further cement smith
as an action star and of course we love
when the fellows make joey pants have a
connection and while six degrees of
separation made hollywood realize smith
was more than just a fun sitcom player
denzel washington and glory left little
room for doubt as to who the next great
actor was going to be the harrowing
glimpses of the mistreatment of black
people fighting for their own lives and
america's civil war still resonate with
power today as does his take on malcolm
x virtually every time he speaks in
particular the slave mind talk and his
prison tutelage under charles s dutton
stand out as oscar-worthy scenarios and
the fact that al pacino won that ear for
scented woman instead i've been around
you know dear academy it's mark again
you know what let's move on to a more
disney version of the presents
washington brings to the screen as coach
herman boone and remember the titans
denzel was able to put us in his shoes
at a time when segregation was still
rampant in schools and folks looked to
sports as the only form of true justice
in america i love his reprimanding of an
assistant coach for coddling the players
but above all else it's the scene during
training camp where an early morning run
to gettysburg summons the ghosts of
those who fought a hundred years ago it
hits hard with his players who are still
learning to work together and is enough
to make an audience member want to run
through a brick wall for coach some of
the best moments of any film are when
two powerhouse actors go back and forth
we get it with washington and gene
hackman and crimson tide in which two
prolific military lifers disagree in the
most dire of nuclear situations the tony
scott film is riveting from start to
finish as is the hilariously playful odd
couple banter between will smith and
tommy lee jones in men in black smith
can achieve an unforgettable rapport
with just about anyone in independence
day alone he has memorable scenes with
fellow pilot harry connick jr and mit
cable repairman jeff goldblum id4 would
have plenty of iconic sequences
regardless of the cast but smith made it
a ride that we would want to keep taking
again and again even after the shock
value of aliens annihilating washington
dc wore off lines like welcome to earth
have been so synonymous with will he now
has a streaming show called that it's 25
years later folks remarkable for denzel
i'd look to the king kong speech towards
the end of training day for quotable
dialogue that is i would until american
gangster hit theaters frank lucas
asserting his dominance over harlem was
solidified by a pleasant breakfast with
his relatives where he just takes a
quick break to shoot idris elba's bumpy
in the head in broad daylight the slow
burn of his homophobic lawyer in
philadelphia peels back the layers of
the american psyche at the time and
flight features some truly unforgettable
scenes that range from the thrill of
whitaker successfully landing a plane
upside down without killing almost
everyone on board to the loneliness and
desperation one feels dealing with
alcoholism the shot of strength falling
prey to addiction is heartbreakingly
authentic in one hotel shot whip sees a
bottle on top of a mini bar leaves the
room and then comes right back snags the
liquor and we know this guy just fell
victim to his demons once again
what sways me towards will smith in this
round is his ability to go intense like
with the sunny listing weigh-in scene
and ali
and how about we also just give him some
love for being able to pull off arguably
the greatest athlete to ever live how
about the quiet fire of dr amalu in
concussion or the exhilaration of chris
getting a job by the end of pursuit of
happiness will can do all of those
things well but he's also delivered some
of the most crowd-pleasing lines in
cinematic history and he made us feel
like kevin james schwab can date way out
of his league bravo will in the toughest
round to call yet i'm giving this w to
the guy who puts butts in seats and
delivers every time will smith earns the
victory and we're tied at 2-2 and now
it's time for the wild card round legacy
it all comes down to this and if you're
a sports fan like me this is the two
minute drill the final shot three balls
two strikes bottom of the ninth and i'll
be honest my versus enthusiast i began
writing this round and i had no idea who
was gonna win none i know the answer now
because i wrote it and now we're taping
it but you get where i'm going the
suspense is real whoever wins is going
to have earned it and whoever loses i'll
probably get a lot of hate mail on their
behalf when we talk about legacy i
always start with the movies and
performances that we know these two best
for but in the case of denzel and
especially will deeds done outside the
talking picture should be allowed to
factor in as well after all we're
talking about legacy here it's the sum
total of one's career and life so far
and for will smith that has been a
monumental transition he wasn't supposed
to be a movie star originally he was a
musician with his pal jazz then he
became a tv star then he did some movies
they got bigger and bigger and now we
can't imagine a world without will smith
at the multiplex his diversity in the
realm of cinema is nothing short of
remarkable he can make us laugh with
hitch thrill us with i am legend save
the city and also wreck it with bad boys
save earth with independence day and
through it all he can charm his way into
our hearts the dude's got every section
of blockbuster video covered especially
the most coveted aisle new releases his
performance in king richard could win an
oscar but more importantly it's a sign
that will smith is going to keep
surprising us in the years and decades
to come if will needs any tips on how to
approach giving an oscar acceptance
speech he might want to text his buddy
denzel washington he's been on that
stage twice with a statue and he could
keep will in his seat at this next
ceremony courtesy of macbeth but even
though denzel first rose to prominence
on a popular tv series he always seemed
ready to ascend onto the big screen his
first oscar nomination was for cry
freedom and it was the opening salvo of
what would become a career for all times
he's now known as one of if not the
greatest actors to ever do the job
outside the studio a lot the influence
of denzel washington has been as
effective as it is understated he
doesn't go around bragging about all the
young careers he's mentored and he'll
never have to the generations of young
thespians that came after washington
have been effusive in their praise of
what he's meant to them in getting their
start in hollywood michael b jordan and
chadwick boseman are just two examples
of the talent that denzel helped nurture
in fact bozeman was able to study
dramatic arts at oxford university
because of a scholarship endorsed by
washington in an affi speech bozeman
noted that what mattered even more than
the amount you gave is that it was you
doing the giving there is no black
panther without denzel washington
someone else who often looked at denzel
for advice was none other than will
smith as he explained in a recent gq
article but for will he might need
washington now as just an ear to listen
smith seems to have figured out the
entire entertainment industry just fine
at his peak mr fourth of july success
will smith was a summer hit machine that
wasn't just limited to a movie theater
it was on the radio as well his
accompanying men in black albums sold 3
million copies and willenium which
featured wild wild west sold another 2
million and my niece and nephews loved
that song and have no idea it was a
movie and that's probably for the best
the question really boils down to this
do you take the guy who's become
arguably the best ever at his craft or
should it be the guy who has yet to meet
an art form he can't master it's so
close i'll look to anything else i can
find to sway me okay denzel washington
has become one of the most popular gifts
in history anytime it's someone famous
that's trending we get worried about
their health or what they did wrong and
when we realize it's just their birthday
we put out the denzel sigh of relief but
will smith just published one of the
most widely read books of last year it
details his life career and is filled
with sage advice from a guy who can do
it all and it's a reminder that life is
so short and precious but can also last
a long time so there's always room to
try something new and if i'm pressed to
make a decision i'm pretty sure will
could win an oscar before denzel wins a
grammy although i'd love to be proven
wrong so in a legendary match between
two titans it comes down to the wire
i'm going with jim west
uh i'm sorry will smith takes the wild
card round and thus the match
you think you can do this to me
you motherfu to be playing basketball in
pelican bay when i get finished with you
and we can also employ that denzo
washington relief gift because he is the
acting goat look this was one of the
toughest calls i've ever had to make in
the storied history of this show credit
to both performers for being such great
sports about it or at least watching the
vid maybe or if you want to retweet it
happy to what you all can do is follow
me at my social media handle at mark
ellis and for upcoming stand-up shows in
your city head to mark ellis dot live
see cuz i perform live and dot com was
so two thousand thanks for watching this
episode of versus it kind of felt like
the jordan versus lebron debate right it
might depend on your entry point into
earth as to who you lean towards one day
lebron could overtake mike or it becomes
exactly even like magic versus bird
except i might take magic there you see
how hard my job is i do and do for you
kids and what's the thanks i get
oh right you watch the show thanks for
tuning in to versus i'm mark ellis and
i told the truth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]